thank you
do please continue cabinet secretary
thank you presiding officer and can I
say as a woman I know what a woman is
and I know the challenge faced by women
in our society
the experience in the many countries has
been a beneficial impact on the lives of
trans people with no evidence of a
negative impact for others we've said
this throughout the passage of the bill
and I again refer to the work of Victor
Madrigal barlowes whose researched
outcomes in those countries and found
the outcomes in terms of social
inclusion and the decrease in violence
against trans people are remarkable I
think we could all hope that trans
people in Scotland will also be able to
benefit from those positive outcomes as
the bill removes barriers to the
enjoyment of their human rights
I want to end with a a plea to msps to
perhaps agree something that we can all
move forward with a point of agreement
whether or not you vote for this bill
I hope that we can unite and agree to
tackle and challenge transphobia
wherever and whenever it occurs and it
can occur anywhere even within this
Parliamentary Building and I'm sad to
see that I'm aware of a trans woman who
is in this estate who was referred to as
it by an MSP to another colleague now
presiding officer that has nothing to do
with protecting women and girls but has
everything to do with transphobia so
let's agree that the othering of a
minority within our society is totally
totally wrong and if we
hear such Prejudice here in this
Parliament or anywhere else that we call
it out for what it is because we are
better than that
I want to end
I want to end with a quote from Martin
Luther King Jr who said we are caught in
a inescapable network of mutuality tied
in a single Garment of Destiny whatever
affects one directly affects us all
indirectly residing officer I want to
thank members again for their
contributions to this debate and I want
to commend this bill and the motion to
Parliament and I urge members to support
it
thank you
that concludes the debate on gender
recognition reform Scotland bill
the question is that motion 7312 in the
name of Shona Robison on gender
recognition reform Scotland will be
agreed and there will be a brief pause
to allow members to access the digital
voting system
foreign
yeah
foreign
the question is that motion
7312 in the name of Shona Robison on
gender recognition reform Scotland will
be agreed and members should cast their
votes now
foreign
quite important
the vote is closed point of order Ben
McPherson officer my option to vote did
not come up I would have voted yes
thank you we'll ensure that's recorded
thank you
the results of the vote on motion 7312
in the name of Shona Robison is yes 86
no 39 there were no extensions the
motion is therefore agreed and the
gender recognition reform Scotland bill
is passed
foreign
thank you thank you all we will continue
with business
thank you
the next
we will suspend business